andy i need evidence got it wait you
don't know what evidence ah right on yes
hit me next to my desk is a picture of a
female politician bella abzug is that
scary face funny hat gap tooth or bill
clinton's wife funny hat funny hat on
the back of it is a key taped to it and
then that opens my bottom drawer and my
desk get
[Laughter]
what's happening
sorry i lost it
you got bored in the middle of them
[Music]
oh [ __ ] that's funny okay okay
[Laughter]
andrew i need evidence got it wait you
don't know what evidence ah right on yes
hit me next to my desk is a picture of a
female politician bella abzug get the
key that's taped in the back of that
picture it opens up my bottom desk
drawer and there are some files pay
attention where are you looking look
here focus here get the files in the
drawer and then get all of the file
boxes in the office put the files in the
drawer let's go no okay i'll go with
them thank you man i'm in love with you
because you're just like me you're a dog
date me ann i'm single
[Laughter]
ron you're gonna construct the stage yes
ma'am
i really think we should try and involve
this talking dog
and will you go out on a date with me
you're the prettiest dog i've ever seen
damn remember when we had sex in the
gutter on rodney street i'll never
forget her dad
i'm gonna come over there and [ __ ] you
up
[Laughter]
everyone loves a good comeback story
right
seabiscuit the mighty ducks robert
downey jr
uh rocky yes kim kardashian kim well wow
in the video she gets she gets to come
on her back i think
[Laughter]
so leslie and i have come up with the
theme
for the campaign relaunch rally the
comeback kid
everyone loves a good comeback story
rocky robert downey jr terminator said
i'll be back and he was also making a
comeback the casual hawaiian shirt
well well look who's ahead of the curve
i was joking she'd soak that in bleach
and burn it okay so the rally is going
to be held tomorrow at the pawnee sports
building april you finalized a rental
right shut up ann i told you never to
talk to me
that was champion oh my god i'm sorry
bad dog yes everything's fine with the
rental
i'm gonna go to the bathroom and powder
my nose
amongst other things
if you know what i mean
dude is she gonna powder her vagina
[Laughter]
i'm sorry
dude is she gonna powder
[Laughter]
can we just get it on the next steak
yeah yeah okay okay
okay
[Laughter]
i'll have another drink and so will this
adorable hunk of caramel to my right
drink up tom
i'm gonna go powder my nose amongst
other things
if you know what i mean
is she gonna powder her vagina you gotta
help me man why it seems to be going the
usual amount of gross no this is way
different she's not married anymore she
had like five bottles of alcohol she's
calling me caramel you've got to throw
some cold water on this situation start
talking about nerd stuff you know nerd
culture is mainstream now so when you
use the word nerd derogatorily means
you're the one that's out of the
zeitgeist yes that's perfect just like
that be incredibly boring who my name is
annabelle vandercrank from the memphis
van der cranks and i just about lose my
head when the sun falls down
[Laughter]
i'm sorry i need my mustache glued
whose club do you think is better yours
are mine
the answer is mine say mine is better
it's not a competition
oh but it is
your club made it a competition when
they kept girls out oh my stars i'm just
a little lady my fragile constitution
cannot handle the fearsome outdoors i
have no problem with strong women
who's
leslie
my name is annabelle vandergraff and
y'all
i just fall to pieces when the sun
shines on my head
will you just help me open this
is it really
thank you what i was saying is that
awesome girls like you who are you know
not classically hot they can go and they
can be rewarded for
an idiot
[Laughter]
hey
hey
so i was just at the grind and i thought
you might want an iced mocha with extra
extra whipped cream
oh my thank you so much april wow you're
welcome oh by the way
completely unrelated i just signed up
for the miss pawnee beauty pageant
that's wonderful you know that is why i
decided to become a judge
so that awesome girls like you who are
not you know classically hot can be
rewarded for their intelligence and
savvy would you gentlemen like a tour
not at all there is quite literally
nothing in the world that i would rather
do
than take a tour of the parks and rec
department
hello there hi chris trager this is ben
hello gents ron swanson ron
swanson
okay
i'm deputy director leslie knope and
leslie
nope
it is fantastic to be here would you
gentlemen like a tour oh there is quite
literally nothing i would rather have in
the world than a tour of the parks and
recreation department of the great city
of pawnee led by ron swanson
and leslie knope
okay
ben i don't think that's a great idea
let's do it okay step one
we buy into this club
step two we roll over to the club either
near mercedes-benz which is gorgeous or
my pre-owned acura legend which is all
right step three i dagger you on the
dance floor
just bounce bounce bounce
bounce
bounce bounce bounce the bounce now
everybody's watching
i'm so sorry
step three
i dagger you on that dance floor
and dress you with my eyes
until at last it's just me and you naked
on the dance floor
you're gonna throw up you're gonna smile
this must be the lovely donna ashante
listen beautiful let's cut the bowl
right you want this
i definitely want this t.h wants this
let's seal this devil's three-way right
here right now step one we buy into this
club step two we roll over to the club
either in your mercedes-benz or my
pre-owned acura legend step three i
dagger you on the dance floor just
bounce bounce bounce bad sound now all
the ladies say and bounce bounce bounce
bounce bounce
what do you say sexy
i'm out why i hate that guy
bye carl
leslie i'd rather be back at the office
i know this is painful for you jerry but
you have to be strong
you guys ready
oh boy yeah okay we're ready sometimes
when i wipe
i'll wipe and i'll wipe and i'll wipe
and i'll wipe
a hundred times
still poop still poop let me check that
it's like i'm wiping a marker or
something
well if it's a concussion it's extremely
mild so i wouldn't worry about it
anything else bothering you
nope
okay well i mean yeah i've got a weird
uh rash in my knee pit
area and my tongue on this side doesn't
taste anything anymore sometimes when i
walk my ankles make like a weird rattle
snake sound what else things that are
far away from my eyes are fuzzy i once
ate a twix with the wrapper on it and
i've never seen the wrapper come out
also i've swallowed every piece of gum
that i've chewed for the past 25 years i
don't know
i broke my thumb on the way over here it
just
fixed me
well i can help you with the thumb and
i'll have to give you referrals for
specialists for the other thousand
things wow thanks for nothing dr harris
you're welcome
i got it i got it
nice oh yeah
i also got some dude's briefcase i
believed in you buddy but you should put
that back
yeah how did you get this
well what
that is
[ __ ] hilarious you shattered the
lights you shattered it not only did you
hit the wall that's a wrap
that's not something that props can fix
that's gonna be a little harder to fix
i'm sorry i'm out
got it got
it nice
i also got this dude's briefcase who's
just laying there kind of a panic move
i believed in you
but you shouldn't put that back okay
you